des princes les bizarreries de dame
nature monstre animaux naturalisés
squelette humain en tout genre tout cela
est visible au musée d'anatomie de
maisons alfort fermé depuis deux siècles
ce vieux musée qui datent de 1766 était
jusqu alors réservé aux étudiants en
école vétérinaire il est enfin ouvert au
public
c'est un drôle d'univers vous allez voir
un peu macabre même avec en vedette les
18 écorché de l'anatomiste honoré
fragonard le cousin germain du peintre
anne morin christian fienga le gardien
de ces lieux et dante et le nez cassé
il est figé depuis deux siècles
l'écorché vif à ses pieds la danse
macabre de 3 foetus 3 gnolls diabolique
qui sautille comme pour esquisser une
mazurka
fragonard mètres en dix sections et mais
aussi la mise en scène sa pièce
maîtresse le cavalier et son cheval au
galop alors obsession morbide ou génie
de l'anatomie et on enlever la peau le
côté morbide disparaît complètement et
on a plus que l'attrait où l'intérêt
pour les buses retrouver le chemin des
vaisseaux c'est un vrai jeu de piste en
fait on recherche les nerfs les
vaisseaux et c'est donc on oublie
complètement le côté un petit peu
rébarbative voire abominables que peut
avoir pour le commun des mortels 17e le
musée fragonard de maisons alfort se
réveille d'une longue léthargie de deux
siècles
il en a conservé de la poussière une
odeur d'encaustiqué de formol le charme
suranné des cabinets de curiosités
composition autour d'organes génitaux
urinaire datés et signés petitcolin
spécialiste en la matière
d'un côté les mâles dromadaires toro
lyon jusqu au poulet de l'autre les
femelles un utérus de truies moulages en
plâtre de 1908 une pièce artistique mais
aussi didactique
tout comme ses viscères ans intestin ou
estomac insuffler sécher couronné par
celui d'un chameau du cirque barnum
mais la nature a aussi ses sautes
d'humeur et lui prend parfois
d'engendrer des monstres veau à deux
têtes
ou bien siamois
ils sont soudés pour l'éternité
sous le regard dérangeant des cyclopes
qui leur font face les glorieux
descendants des monstres mythologiques
de l'antiquité